devant lui un interlocuteur intelligent
habile très bien préparés qu'ils étaient
assez volubile qui nous a dit plein de
choses ça ne résout en rien les
contradictions auxquelles on a affaire à
la france demandé presque si ce n'est
pas le président de la république qui
protège et alexandre bédat là parce
qu'il a l'air d'être vraiment en danger
ce garçon puisque sur le sujet du port
d'armes
finalement c'est pour raisons
personnelles faille à une confusion
entre le professionnel le personnel le
public le privé qui n'est pas dissipées
au contraire c'est pour se protéger
lui-même dans le cadre des fonctions qui
pouvait le mettre en danger c'était là
sa réponse est plus ou moins celle de
yann drouet même si on n'était pas
certain que les deux disent exactement
la même chose on a une ligne de crête
entre ses fonctions de coordination
d'organisations et ses fonctions
deux missions de sécurité de protection
du président de la république on voit
que la ligne jaune a été franchie on le
sent d'ailleurs il ya certaines réponses
qui sont contradictoires
on voit notamment sur la question que
j'ai posée à la fin s'agissant des
fouilles des contrôles d'identité avec
des journalistes
on lui parle de la mongie et de
marseille nous répond la guyane
appelle-nous répond-t-il il ya quand
même là derrière évidemment une
confusion des genres
le croyez-vous quand il dit qu'il n'a
jamais été le garde du corps d'emmanuel
macron que ce soit pendant la campagne
que ce soit depuis qu'il est président
de la république
rien n'est clair au fond parce qu'on
n'aime que joue confusion qu'il tient
sans doute à ses aspirations
personnelles à sa fascination pour les
fonctions de sécurité et à un trouble
dans l'organisation administrative et
les missions qui lui ont été confiées et
je crois qu'on ressort que l'on verra ce
que dit le rapport à ce que dit la
commission des lois
on ressort de l'ensemble de ces
auditions avec le sentiment quand même
que tout ça est très ambigu qu'est-ce
que cela pose quand même problème si
alexandre benalla a été effectivement en
charge de la sécurité rapprochée du
président de la république c'est le
problème que ça pose c'est que ces
fonctions de sécurité avec
le chef de l'état
ne sont pas assurées par des gens qui
sont compétents pour cela on a des
fonctionnaires de police
on a des militaires dont c'est le métier
j'espère le gspr exemple et là on a
quelqu'un qui arrive par la voie
militante par une voix oblique pour
assurer des missions qui ne sont pas les
siennes donc il ya eu des erreurs
organisation à l'elysée que emmanuel
macron à souhaiter ça prouve qu'ils
avaient du travail est inférieure à
desservir directeur général des services
donc ça n'était pas clair ça n'est
toujours pas clair et ça traduit sans
doute ce que on sent comme trouble du
côté de l'exécutif et comme inquiétude
la déontologie laquelle monsieur prévost
fait allusion c'est sans doute beaucoup
de beaucoup de dents nuit de troubles
pour justifier tout ce qui s'est passé
l'elysée